me
みなさんこんにちは東京大学の川原です
今日は羽田での公演ということでせっかくなので紙飛行機を作ってきました
この紙ひこうキーちょっと表面が銀色してますが実は銀後
打てるインクジェットプリンターこれでちょっとした回路を作っつけています
今バッテリーを付けると
プロペラがこのように回り出します見えますかねえ
飛ぶかな
だけます
桜区
大成功ですねはい
ありがとうございます
この紙飛行機
あのあこの回路を作る技術を私は東京大学で研究しています
この研究が生まれるに至った経緯ちょっとしたエピソード
話したいと思いますそれがこうタイトルにあるがいる場合だ財布
側に方割に立って助けるということです
そもそも大学ではですね研究と教育
それからあなたは企業という新たな3つのあの技術が3つの側面があります
一つは教育者これは学問体系だった学問を生徒に教えることで新たな人材を作るという
ようなことです
もう一つ研究ですねこちらは
研ぎ澄まし極めることつまり真理の探究であったりとか新たな発明を行うこと
こういったことが求められている
ok です
でさらに最近言われ始めていることが大学がイノベーションの源になる
すなわち新たに作った研究を基にして産業を作るあるいは社会に存在の様々なかゆ課題
を解決する
そういうことが求められるようになっています
ところがまあ大学というのは
昔からですねまあこのような形でほとんど変わっていません
今でもダイコー daiko 議員の大人数の教室ですね
先生が壇上の上に立って一方的に知識を教えるというのが
まあ中心的な抗議の仕方だと思います
ところがこういう
抗議の仕方っていうのはまあその先ほどのイノベーションを生むってまあ少し
そぐわないんじゃないのかなというふうに思っています
私のこれまでの経験を少しお話したいと思います
私が大学に入ったのは1996年
ちょうど windows 95が発売されてインターネットがこれから社会を変える
のではないかそういうふうに期待されてた時代です
東京大学の理科1類に入ってその後工学部の電子情報工学科に入りましたそこで最新の
インターネットの技術が学べると思ってワクワクして猛勉強の成果がここで向かわれる
と思って期待して入りました
ところがまあ今思えば当然なんですけれども
そこで習う技術は非常に基礎的なもの王様とは程遠い
もう何十年も前に行く研究あの開発された
あるいは確立されたそういう技術です
私は正直モチベーションを保つことがなかなか難しかったんです
まあ今思えば教員になって思い返してみればこの時代に非常に基礎を叩き込む店大事な
ことなんですけどまぁそれは気づくのは10年20年先ということになります
まあようやくモチベーションおこう撮り直し取り戻してですね
大学で研究をする楽しみを得たのは大学に入ってからでした
当時
雪はユビキタスコンピューティングという言葉が社会で認知されるようになりました
マークはいざーさんという方が提唱されたコンセプトです
昔はこちらのグラフに青いグラフにありますように
非常に高価なコンピューターをみんなで使うしかないという時代でした
それがピンクのライン
少しコンピューターの値段が安くなってパソコンを1人1台持てるようになりました
そのトレンドがさらに続くと緑のライン一人一人一人がたくさんのコンピューターに
囲まれて豊かな生活を送れるそういった時代が来るのではないかというふうに言われて
いました
このコンセプトに非常に強い共感を覚えまして私は自分の手でこの技術に貢献したい
そんな風に思うようになりました
私が研究テーマとして選んだのはその中でコンピュータを非常に安くするということ
です
印刷技術を使ってコンピュータセンサーこういったものを丸禰衡紙に絵文字をするかの
ように非常に安く作りたい
このために開発したのがこちらの技術です家庭用のインクジェットプリンターに議員の
インクを詰め
パソコンでパターンを作ってそのまま印刷するだけで回路が出来上がります
わかりやすいように今はペンに同じ淫行詰めたものでデモをしていますけれども
こちらように電池を置くだけで
光る回路が即座に出来上がります
私のこの技術ですがその後2013年に
2013年にジョージア工科大学あるいは松任
microsoft 研究所と一緒に共同研究して
国際会議ですね学会で
発表しました指君と指コンプという国際会議だったんですけれども
幸いなことに私たちの研究はへ
スノーとして最も優秀な研究 best paper を受賞しました
この研究は私のキャリアの中でも最も
まあターニングポイントになった重要な成果でした
こういうふうにさらっと話すと非常に順調に聞こえるかもしれないんですけど実はこの
論文ペストペーパーを取る前に別の各階に出して
リジェクトされましたリジェクトターン落とされたという意味ですね研究論文を発表
するのは自分の意思だけではできません
いい論文を書いてそれをコミュニティで選んで専門家が選んで発表する価値があるか
どうか
いうのを判断されますこの文面はあの落とされたときのあのリジェクト通知そのまま
です
書いてあることはですねまあ非常に面白いと思うんだけれどもあなたの貢献というのは
ちょっとわかりにくい
似たような技術がたくさんある
あなたはやった事本当に大事だった事本当の貢献というのは何ですか
いうことを問われていましたその通りでした
私はまぁ中身さえ良ければきっとこの想いは伝わるだろうという独りよがりな論文を
書いていきたすぎませんでした
言ってみれば形が定まらないどこがポイントなのかよくわからない
こういう論文書いてしまいましたちゃんとロングを通すためにはこれを
はっきりと特徴のあるような形に仕上げなければいけません
ここで私が撮ったストラテジーはですね
実はライバルの研究者にこの
謙虚インクを使ってみる使ってもらうということでした
研究においては時間との競争ですのでライバルに恋手の内を明かすというのはご法度
です
も論文が通るまでは秘密にするというのが鉄則なんですけれども
あえてここを
敵に塩を送るようなことをしてみました
結果だけ言うと実はそれが非常に好走しました
あまりこうな付き合いのなかった研究者なんですけど誰よりも喜んでくれたのはそのへ
情報をもらった hey
共同研究者でした後の共同研究者でした
彼との彼らとのそのディスカッションの中でここはどうなってんだあれはどうなってん
だ
ここはなんでこうやったらこうなるんだ2疑問遅くにぶつけられたことによって自分が
やった貢献っていうのがはっきり見えるようになりました
幸いそのライバルだった研究者が共同研究室の仲間に入ってくれてそのままこのロング
の出版につながりました
この技術は現在私が事業を教えた
まぁ欲しい子たちによって実用化されています
この技術をは今ですねこの a ジック株式会社によって
インクそれからへ
プリンターそういったものを世界中に販売することによって産業用途であったり
エンターテインメントであったりあるいはこの一番右の写真のように教育用途であっ
たりそういったいろんな現場で活用されています
論文書くだけだとなかなか技術を世に出すことは難しいんですけどもこうやって教え子
たちが会社をつくってくれたことで
私の想いいろんな人にこの技術を届けたい
いろんな人の校友会をつくりたいそういう希望を間接的に叶えることができたのかなと
思っています
ただそもそもこの技術はコンピューターセンサーを安くしたいという目的で作りました
ある日農家の方と出会いましたその方は茨木で有機野菜を大規模に作っている農家さん
でした
トマトを作る hey
音質をたくさん管理しているんですけれども春日その
農家の方はですねあのひとつ一つハウスによって微妙にこう味が違うことに気づいて
しまいました
実はトマトの味特に糖度は水をどれだけ上手にあげられたかによって大きく変わります
プロなのでそれを完璧にコントロールしているというふうに思われていたんですけれど
もそれが正
玉造さん社長さんのナットクメイクレベルまで行けないということに気付き付いたそう
です
そこで私たちはですねこれこの技術を使ってですね
従来のよりも非常に安いコストでセンサーを作ることができました
既存のセンサーですと意識数十万円してしまいます
トマトが a
トマトのハウスを50歩100個
管理しているような大きな農家さんで110倍100倍の投資が必要になります
なかなかそれは難しい私たちの戦争は従来の10分の1のセンサーん価格のセンサーを
目指して作っています
ある意味で私たちはまたまつくりさんと一緒の運命を
目的を叶えるために
会社を設立しセンサーを開発しているということも言えます
こちらの写真は
一緒に会社を創っている仲間たちです
株式会社線スプレーを払うと仲間達です農家さんのフィードバックを得て先ほどの
私たちが作ったプロタイプが全然違う形になってきました
私はそれでいいと思っています
現在
google あるいはスマートフォンでほとんど世界中の知識に簡単にアクセス
できるようになりました
正しい答えを見つけて下さいそういうことをインターネットに聞くとほぼ正しい答えが
返ってくるような時代です
現在の教育は知識を一方的に教える多いもでは全然通用しません
むしろ
イノベーションを起こすためには次に何をすべきかどういうことが問題になるべきかと
そういったことを
考えられる思いつける人材育成が必要なんじゃないのかなと思っています
人というのは自分の視点がいったん定まってしまうと案外
他の味方をすることができません
ところが正
皆さん違う人々ですので案外隣に立って同じものを見てたとしても違うものを見ている
可能性だってあります
多くの人は人の役に立ちたいイノベーションを期したい
だけどまぁ自分にそんなスキルがない向かないという風に自分の能力を過小評価して
いるかもしれません
でも私が経験したのは何か困ってる人いろんな人のところに会いに行って
つまりで話を聞くそして自分の視点を伝えるこういう非常に小さな
貢献がイノベーションにつながるということをまあこの研究開発を通じて感じており
ました
私のスタンスは壇上で知識を教えるのではなく
いろんな人の欲側に立ちそして導く
これを私のスタイル通していますありがとうございます